[Aplausos]
[Música]
una vez más en lo que ya casi resulta
como una historia interminable korea
está que arde parecía que las
negociaciones de paz entre corea del
norte corea del sur y eeuu iban por el
buen camino sin embargo lejos de cantar
victoria la cosa podría haberse cruzado
otra vez queridos amigos amigas las
conversaciones de paz que se han
producido durante los últimos años han
supuesto el periodo de estabilidad más
largo en la península de corea en los
últimos 20 años
y todo esto gracias a este hombre el
presidente de corea del sur
muniaín ha hecho del acercamiento avión
jané el principal objetivo de su
gobierno un acercamiento que en última
instancia persigue la firma de un
acuerdo de paz que ponga de una vez por
todas fin a la guerra de corea
porque desde 1953 esta guerra sigue
técnicamente abierta tan solo está
detenida por un armisticio para un
lograr la paz de la península de corea
sería también una forma de rendir
tributo a su mentor el ex presidente roh
moo hyun para el que trabajo la casa
azul y que fue el que continuó la
sunshine policy del ex presidente kim
sin embargo ahora a menos de dos años de
terminar su mandato y en contra todo
pronóstico el sueño de mucho de lograr
semejante éxito político podría haberse
truncado de forma definitiva y la
pregunta que ahora podemos hacernos es
qué ha pasado exactamente para que de
repente las conversaciones de paz hayan
saltado por los aires tendrán un tiempo
suficiente para reencaminar los diálogos
hacia la paz qué papel juega a eeuu trap
en las elecciones de noviembre en todo
este lío y tal vez la pregunta más
importante de todas y estaremos
presenciando el ascenso de un nuevo
liderazgo en corea del norte en este
vídeo os lo contamos atentos
la alegoría de una explosión controlada
fijaos en estas imágenes
eso que habéis visto saltando por los
aires no es ni más ni menos que la
oficina de enlace intercoreana este
lugar se estableció en septiembre del
2018 y funcionaba en la práctica como
una especie de embajada un lugar donde
reunirse y avanzar en las negociaciones
entre ambas coreas sin embargo el
régimen comunista decidió el pasado 16
de junio del 2020 utilizar una enorme
carga de explosivos para hacer volar
este edificio por los aires una
explosión que simboliza cómo se las
gastan y cómo entiende las negociaciones
en pyongyang este amigos ha sido el
último órdago del régimen norcoreano un
órdago que comenzó con el corte
unilateral de la línea telefónica que
utilizan ambos países para hablar y
coordinar asuntos de índole militar y
civil
corea del norte corta todas las líneas
de comunicación con corea del sur pero
la explosión de la oficina de enlace fue
lo que cayó como todo un jarro de agua
fría en el gobierno de münchen y por así
decirlo ha sido básicamente la viva
representación de como corea del norte
ha hecho saltar por los aires unos
diálogos de paz que ya llevaban más de
dos años en marcha un punto y aparte en
una historia en un repentino romance que
a decir verdad en pyongyang nunca se
terminaron de creer del todo
y ojo porque esta explosión no lleva a
la firma no ha sido ordenada
directamente por kim jong-un como es
habitual y como podríamos sospechar sino
por su hermanísimo kim jong de la que ya
os hablamos en un reciente vídeo sobre
los posibles herederos políticos de
corea del norte
os dejo por cierto el link del video
aquí abajo en la descripción pero un
momento la hermana ordenando destruir el
punto de enlace con corea del sur algo
raro está pasando no os parece luego lo
vamos a ver con detalle pero antes antes
tenemos que echar un vistazo a qué
demonios ha hecho que corea del norte
destruya todos los avances logrados en
los dos últimos años fijaos
unos globos de helio helio se ha montado
por unos globos de helio sí sí lo habéis
escuchado bien hablamos de globos de
helio cargados con folletos cds pendrive
billetes de dólar radios y demás objetos
que sirven para que los norcoreanos se
informen de lo que pasa en el exterior
son lanzados 11 veces al año por un
grupo de desertores norcoreanos
conocidos como los luchadores por una
corea del norte libre un grupo de
activistas liderado por el famoso
desertor pack sand
el objetivo principal de estas acciones
es que sus antiguos conciudadanos puedan
conocer la realidad de lo que ocurre en
el exterior y de esta forma se erosione
la confianza en el régimen pues bien el
último lanzamiento fue el 31 de mayo de
2020 y el siguiente estaba programado
para el mes de junio y fue precisamente
este lanzamiento el que desató la ira de
corea del norte
pero esperar porque me han 3 algo que se
lleva a cabo 11 dieces al año desde hace
un montón de tiempo de repente ahora
enfada tanto al régimen comunista
[Música]
pues bien justo aquí es donde está el
quid de la cuestión digamos que a priori
no tiene mucho sentido hacer saltar por
los aires todos los avances por un tema
que bueno al fin y al cabo no es nuevo y
que tampoco es culpa del gobierno
surcoreano sino de grupos de de sectores
que hacen esto ejerciendo su libertad de
expresión pero es que si además os
contamos que el propio gobierno
surcoreano se puso del lado de corea del
norte entonces la cosa tiene todavía
menos sentido fijaos corea del sur dice
que considera prohibir el lanzamiento de
folletos tras las amenazas de la hermana
de kim cualquier acto que pueda suponer
una amenaza para la vida o la propiedad
de los residentes en el área fronteriza
debe ser detenido dijo el portavoz del
ministerio de unificación george sun kim
jong impone una prohibición de entrada
al área fronteriza para bloquear los
panfletos anti norte los infractores
serán arrestados en la escena y se
enfrentarán a penas de cárcel de hasta
un año o multas de hasta diez millones
de won 8 mil 300 dólares bajo la ley
marco de gestión de desastres y
seguridad si después de años y años
lanzándose con total libertad ahora de
repente a las autoridades surcoreanas
les parece que todo esto de los globos
es una clara amenaza a la vida ya la
propiedad algo que por supuesto como os
podéis imaginar no ha pasado
desapercibido para muchos analistas y
expertos esta decisión
viola la libertad política y la libertad
de expresión de este grupo de activistas
norcoreanos
y
sin embargo a pesar de ello la decisión
de las autoridades surcoreanas se tomó
tras recibir estas amenazas de la
mismísima quintero la hermana del gran
líder hablando claro las autoridades
surcoreanas se verán forzadas a pagar un
alto precio si permiten esta situación
mientras ponen todo tipo de excusas si
fracasan en tomar las medidas necesarias
para frenar el absurdo acto en contra de
nuestros compatriotas será mejor que se
preparen para la posibilidad de la
retirada del ya obsoleto complejo
industrial conjunto de que son seguido
por los tours por el monte kumgang o el
cierre definitivo de la oficina de
enlace intercoreana cuya existencia sólo
añade problemas con la destrucción del
acuerdo en el campo militar que apenas
tiene ya valor
kim jong hermana de kim jong-un por
supuesto la retórica de insultos y
amenazas que la hermanísima kim jong
llevó a cabo durante días no se cebó
sólo con el gobierno surcoreano sino
también con los propios desertores a los
que le llamó de todo menos bonito es una
humana poco menos que animales salvajes
que han traicionado su propio patria
están absortos en actos tan impropios
sin duda son perros mestizos ya que
ladran donde no deberían kim jong bueno
de todas formas siendo justos que esto
te lo diga un líder de corea del norte
todo un halago
[Música]
la cuestión es que todo este asunto ha
generado mucha polémica al fin y al cabo
lo que ha ocurrido es ni más ni menos
que el gobierno de mono ha priorizado
sus relaciones con corea del norte sobre
los derechos políticos en el sur y como
os podéis imaginar eso eso es algo muy
controvertido ojo el trasfondo es más
complejo de lo que parece pensarlo bien
tiene un gobierno democrático limitar
los derechos o la capacidad de actuación
de sus ciudadanos con tal de mejorar sus
relaciones con regímenes tiránicos a
ellos lo dejo nosotros en corea del sur
tenemos nuestra propia soberanía y en
este país democrático la gente tiene
tres derechos básicos y uno de ellos es
la libertad de expresión si los
panfletos son bloqueados
entonces enviaremos drones no nos pueden
parar los hechos y la verdad no pueden
ser detenidos la voz de 45.000
desertores que buscan la verdad
continuará pac sang hak desertor y líder
de luchadores por una corea del norte
libre en cualquier caso de lo peor es
que al final todo esto no ha servido
para nada
pero amigos vayamos a la cuestión más
importante porque esta especie de golpe
en la mesa de kim jong y porque ahora
atentos
[Música]
el empoderamiento de la elegida os lo
contamos en un reciente vídeo sobre lo
que podría pasar en corea del norte es y
falleciese kim jong-un en ese caso la
hermana del dictador quien yo yo tendría
muchas papeletas para ser la sucesora y
amigos tened presente una cosa aunque
los rumores sobre la inminente muerte de
kim jong-un de se disiparon
desaparecieron una vez esté reapareció
en público lo cierto es que el dictador
esté vivo no significa que por ejemplo
no esté enfermo ya sabéis cómo funciona
esto el secretismo del régimen no nos
permite saber con seguridad que está
ocurriendo o cuál es el futuro que le
puede esperar a kim jong pero lo que sí
podemos es deducir lo que pasa en el
régimen analizando su forma de actuar y
lo cierto es que esta última pataleta
norcoreana ha sido muy pero que muy
extraña tan extraña como que el
protagonista elegido para hacer añicos
los dos años de conversaciones de paz no
ha sido el líder kim jong un chino kim
jong y todo esto es algo que tiene
varias lecturas posibles
[Música]
por una parte en términos diplomáticos
el hecho de que sea kim jong y no kim
jong-un quien termine abruptamente los
diálogos es en cierta forma una manera
de menospreciar a corea del sur es decir
de rebajar el nivel de importancia que
aparentemente seúl tiene para pyongyang
al fin y al cabo yo jong es una figura
importante en el régimen pero no es la
figura suprema por lo tanto estaríamos
ante una especie de órdago para
demostrar que corea del sur no es tan
importante para ellos como corea del
norte lo es para el gobierno del mundo
[Música]
esa sería un lectura posible pero si nos
fijamos en las implicaciones que esto
tiene para el propio régimen hay mucha
más tela que cortar con esta operación
inglés jon de muestra o al menos podría
haber querido demostrar que es una mujer
fuerte decidida y sin escrúpulos una
persona capaz de llevar a cabo acciones
contundentes sin que le tiemble la mano
y esto es todo de cara a presentarla
como 'número dos' del régimen o incluso
como la posible sucesora que es algo
fundamental
[Música]
en corea del norte nunca ha existido la
figura del vice líder ni nada que se le
parezca nunca ha existido un 'número
dos' en la cúpula de poder de la
dinastía y es eso precisamente lo que
parece que se está tratando de construir
alrededor de la figura de ellos jone una
segunda figura con poder de decisión y
capaz de operar con cierta independencia
kim jong-un en toda esta historia no ha
dicho ni mú y aunque seguramente él haya
sido el que ha decidido todo lo que se
ha hecho de cara al pueblo y al mundo la
cara visible ha sido su hermana
[Música]
y ojo porque todo esto no acaba aquí
varios expertos surcoreanos en la
materia como por ejemplo del blanco el
ex embajador surcoreano en rusia
consideran que lo que corea del norte ha
hecho es en realidad una maniobra muy
meditada para no tener demasiado
protagonismo de cara a las elecciones
estadounidenses de noviembre de 2020
provocaciones serias como una prueba de
misil intercontinental podrían ser
contraproducentes así que quien ha
debido estar pensando mucho en como no
exagerar con sus cartas hasta noviembre
el ex embajador hui por qué pues porque
una provocación importante para los eeuu
podría suponer todo un tanto por el
planteamiento de política exterior de
joe biden y ya sabemos que kim jong o
unido en el tram se llevan muy bien
pensar un momento empezar de nuevo a
lanzar misiles intercontinentales o
regresar a la senda de las pruebas
nucleares son cosas que si supondrían
una amenaza directa para los eeuu y
claro eso podría ser usado por bailén
para atacar la política hacia corea del
norte de trap e incluso para argumentar
que trump es el causante del
fortalecimiento norcoreano y no olvidéis
amigos el enorme papel que corea del
norte ha tenido en la agenda exterior de
donald trump
el experto del área que salió a la pista
así que esta podría ser una buena
explicación de por qué demonios corea
del norte elegido volar por los aires la
oficina de enlace intercoreana lanzada
hace algunas semanas unos cuantos
misiles de corto alcance o hacer cosas
como esta corea del norte reinstalar los
altavoces de propaganda aunque en tres
días después de ponerlos y sin haberlos
usado la mayoría de esos altavoces
desaparecieron
ya lo veis maniobras extrañas que
parecen querer cabrear y tensar
principalmente a corea del sur y quizás
también a japón pero no al grandioso
algo que podría significar que en corea
del norte no quieren bajo ningún
concepto romper las negociaciones con
washington sino que lo que buscan es
fortalecer a la hermanísima del bar
líder y meterle dedo en el ojo al
gobierno surcoreano por veto saber qué
cosa que es algo que ya se ha convertido
casi en un hobby para los gerifaltes
norcoreanos pero llegados a este punto
turno para ti está acaso corea condenada
a estar dividida para siempre ya no
entenderse entre pueblos hermanos que
busca realmente con el norte dinamitando
por enésima vez las conversaciones de
paz será casi una estrategia para
posicionar a kim jong ante un cambio de
liderazgo en un futuro próximo
dejadnos vuestra opinión aquí abajo en
los comentarios y si os ha gustado este
vídeo no olvidéis darle al botón de like
i suscribiros a visual política así como
dando la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]